spoiler alert spoiler alert spoiler
alert spoiler alert well if you're
watching this you've seen infinity war
so we can talk about Easter eggs or we
can just hold each other maybe just a
few moments of Numb silence it's okay
just let it out this is a healing place
okay I feel better let's talk about some
of these Infinity Ward's surprises
because we have a whole year to wait to
find out what happens next need the
first neat little trick comes right at
the beginning actually in the logo did
you see that they made the I in Studios
into a1 cuz it's been 10 years since
Marvel Studios kicked this whole thing
off with Iron Man and The Incredible
Hulk in 2008 cuz they did I saw it
vanishes origin story may have been
original for this movie but a number of
plot threads and goings on in the film
are at least light references to the
original comics Dino snapping his
fingers to wipe out half the universe's
population is a memorable visual from
the comic books as is dr. Strange's
creepy needle torture by ebony maw and
Peter Parker's snazzy new iron spider
suit right off the top before Thanos
really starts laying waste to everyone
we've come to know and love Tony Stark
and Pepper Potts are talking baby names
Tony drops that he'd consider naming a
kid after a certain eccentric uncle
Morgan could this be a reference to the
Morgan Stark of Marvel Comics a minor
Ironman villain who's always wanted to
wrest control of Stark Industries for
himself maybe just so long as there's no
follow-up questions later Thor refers to
the Avengers as Earth's Mightiest Heroes
a name first given to the group way back
in their 1963 comic book debut back then
the crew consisted of ant-man the Hulk
Iron Man Thor and the wasp hey wait a
minute aren't those the same characters
who are left out of this movie or left
non vaporized at the end of this movie
mmm that's weird
probably just a coincidence what's not a
coincidence is Thor's new toy being
named Stormbreaker
and the comics it wasn't an ax but a
hammer created by Odin and wielded by
the alien warrior beta ray bill by the
weight there was another shout-out to
beta ray bill in thor ragnarok
he was one of the champions featured on
the grandmasters palace
to tell us something while arguing with
Tony Peter makes the case that he needs
a neighborhood in order to be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man this isn't just
a recognizable catchphrase but served as
the title of a Marvel comic book series
in the past might be a good name for a
Spidey sequel if there's going to be one
two baddies ashes now even vision
seeking to run off and settle down into
a normal life is something of a comic
book shout out Tom Kings recent series
vision little worse than a man explores
the androids attempt to become a human
and build himself a human family beyond
just the world of Marvel comics infinity
war throws out references to the entire
universe of pop culture or well the half
of the universe of pop culture that's
left
stark compare zebb aneema to Squidward
from SpongeBob during an early encounter
at another point dr. strange asks Tony
if Peter Parker is his ward
a seeming cross comic publisher shout
out to Dick Grayson and Bruce Wayne's
special relationship
now before infinity war came out
directors Joe and Anthony Russo promised
it would contain a shout-out to TVs
classic Arrested Development well you'll
be pleased to know that they have not
made a huge mistake never-nude tobias
funke a the character played by david
cross is on display in the collectors
ruin museum wearing his familiar Jean
cut-offs he even apparently blew himself
before the movie also maybe it's just me
but when Tony asks strange doctor do you
concur I think this might be a shout-out
to Steven Spielberg's catch me if you
can that movie finds a Leonardo
DiCaprio's con man using the same
phrasing dr. Harris yes do you concur of
course it wouldn't be a Marvel movie
without a Stan Lee cameo he's the one
driving Peter Parker's school bus oh and
that's the Queensboro Bridge they're on
by the way not the one where Green
Goblin killed Gwen Stacy that was the
Brooklyn Bridge get it right imaginary
voice I'm responding to the biggest
shocker cameo in the whole film has got
to be the appearance by Red Skull on
Planet Vermeer when we last saw him way
way back in Captain America the First
Avenger
he'd grabbed hold of the tesseract which
we now realize contain the space stone
it certainly seemed like the stone had
killed
especially because actor Hugo Weaving
famously disliked wearing the extremely
hot prosthetic but now we find out that
he had just been transported to a
distant corner of the universe where he
spends eternity delivering infinity
stone exposition a real living nightmare
this was maybe not a cameo but it was
certainly difficult to spot her
did you notice Fargo the leftovers and
the post star Carrie [ __ ] in the movie
she played Proxima midnight one of
Thanos his children who takes on Black
Widow a co yay and Scarlet Witch and
Wakanda yeah Wow she's almost
unrecognizable behind that helm and in
our grand finale post-credits sequence
Samuel Jackson makes his mother effing
glorious return as Nick Fury alongside
Cobie Smulders as former SHIELD agent
Maria Hill we haven't seen her since age
of Ultron either just so you know right
before fury dissolves into nothingness
he sends a mysterious page into space
based on the logo he sent a message to
none other than Captain Marvel whose big
movie to abuse in March of 2019 so we
only have to wait oh yeah another year
again
curse you foggy don't you think they're
being purposefully cruel here at the
very end of the credits these MCU movies
usually shoutout to the next entry in
the series that will feature the
characters like Captain America will
return in Civil War you know what I'm
talking about this one just says Thanos
will return that's it
Earth's Mightiest Heroes are dead and we
have to watch the sunset with grimace
for all eternity
oh yeah that's another pop-culture
reference they call Thanos grimace like
the purple guy from McDonaldland anyway
that's it half the universe is destroyed
thanks for watching let's suggest
letting us know your favorite infinity
war moment makan
below but half the universe is destroyed
so that hardly seems important
[Applause]